donald trump jr rallied supporters at
the ahern hotel
this is part of the trump campaign's
final push here in nevada
8 news now reporter orco mana spoke to
dr trump jr about
what he says the silver state should
vote red this tuesday
i spoke to donald trump jr in a
one-on-one interview this afternoon and
he says nevadans
have a clear choice this tuesday on
election day and that is his father
president donald trump
before i talked with him trump jr held a
make america great again rally here at
the ahern hotel
trump jr speaking to a couple hundred
trump supporters
the president's son blasting democratic
nominee joe biden
calling biden corrupt and ineffective
during his decades-long career
as a washington politician trump jr also
touted what he calls his father's
greatest achievements
while in the white house that includes
president trump's handling of the
economy
and his foreign policy in the middle
east trump jr also says that he stands
by
recent comments that he and the
president have made about the
coronavirus despite a spike in cases
no one's downplaying the virus we're
looking at actual numbers if you look at
where the u.s is trending relative to
the rest of the world we've gotten ahead
of this
when you look at the damage that would
be done by doing the endless lockdown
shutting down the entire country joe
biden's plan let's shut down the country
for three years
you lose your job you lose your
livelihood you lose your home your
marriage
turned to drugs and alcohol the damage
that would be done from that
is far worse than anything the virus
could do the crowd at this afternoon's
event also heard from other gop
candidates for office here in nevada
everyone urging supporters to show up to
the polls this tuesday
to vote for republicans up and down the
ticket i also asked donald trump jr
about
comments that he and the president have
been making about casting doubt on the
mail-in process of course we have
mail-in voting here in nevada
for more on my interview with trump jr
head to 8newsnow.com
reporting in las vegas orca mana 8 news
now